Hello everyone, how are you? This is Jen
with next level commander. I know I've
been gone for a while and actually my
break was going to be longer but then
this happened and this this this and all
this. So I figured okay, it's a good
time to come back and holy crap, have
you seen these designs from the mystery
packs? These are wild. These are pretty
much the greatest hits from the custom
magic forms. Now I know that R&D they
claim they cannot look at custom designs
just like how they do not look at card
prices on the secondary market. But holy
crap, this set is basically decades of
dreams and memes accumulated into one
epic set. So better start saving up now
because the printer ink is going to go
up in price. So anyways, the one that
stood out to me was actually this guy. I
know I know there are cooler and
flashier ones out there and we'll get to
them but somehow this guy just stood out
to me. Now I'm a lover of animals, I
love them in all shapes and sizes,
grilled, barbecued but this guy,
Gendahr, he loves them as much as I do.
Beasts, camels, horses, elephants and
wolves, this guy doesn't care about the
species as long as it's ridable, you're
in. And that's a pretty big range when
it comes to tribal. And the payoff here
is pretty excellent. The saddle
creatures get bigger, we draw cards and
we get a bunch of food tokens. Yeah,
lots of synergies we can do artifact
synergies, we can do life gain. Imagine
this with extra combat. Yeah, we are in
the right colors for all of that. Should
be pretty straightforward. So excitedly
I open up Scryfall and
the drop off is pretty steep. It's
mostly just beasts
and some wolves but camels and horses
they're not going to be doing much. A
few decent elephants. So I tried to put
it together and the deck doesn't run
well because when you're playing these
fatties that are good but not amazing so
you got to ramp a bunch and the ones you
drop them you have to saddle them so you
need another set of creatures to tap and
yeah, again it's the same problem as
vehicle. Yeah, this is not going to
work. So we decided to take another
approach. I mean the commander again,
the ability is really freaking good and
when you have a commander like this I
don't think the individual creature
quality is huge. Again, take Yuriko as
an example, you would take a 1 1 flying
ninja over these huge bomb ones any day.
Now Gendahr is no Yuriko, but there are
some parallels. If we just go small,
we'll maximize the card draw, and this
will give us enough gas to stay in the
game and maybe find something to work
with the food tokens, I don't know. And
we get to make another trip to our
favorite landmark, the trash bin behind
the LGS. So, that seems like a plan, but
once again, we have another hurdle,
which is the tapping, cuz we got to
saddle them. And I don't know about you,
but tapping a Crocsaur War Chief to
saddle a Young Wolf doesn't feel like
the most efficient play. But then, I
remembered my Captain America deck. If
the vehicles can ride each other, why
can't the animals? Unfortunately, we
don't have the sick untapping of Captain
America, but we have card draw. So, we
get to play garbage narrow cards that
are situationally really good. And in
this case, I'm talking about these, the
untap spells. One mana untap everything,
mobilize, vitalize, all these sweet
elegant one-word names wasted on cards
that end up sitting around collecting
dust. Well, not anymore.
Oh, I think they missed garbage day.
Still smells better than LGS. And moving
up the mana value ladder, we have to
arms, Russet Arrester, Rampage,
Benefactor's Insight.
Village Bell-Ringer, and finally Great
Oak Guardian. I'm not sure this one is
worth the mana cost, to be honest, but
the pump is pretty sweet. But what's
really good are these extra combat ones.
Now, not all of them work, but these
ones I've chosen can serve as an untap
spell in a pinch. Although ideally, you
want both combats. Full throttle here is
the full package. You untap everything
before each combat, and you get three of
them. So, you get all the draw, all the
tokens, and the plus two plus two
stacks. So, once again, that's the best
finisher, no surprise here. And now, we
get to meet the animals. And like I said
earlier, pretty much the only criteria I
looked at is mana cost. Not even power.
Like if it's got lower than two power,
whatever, we'll we'll double saddle
something. And our goal here is to curve
out early and start drawing ASAP. But
unfortunately, even with lowered
standards, our options are very limited.
That's an oddly familiar feeling. But
we're starting on a high note with Young
Wolf. Oh, it's a good card. It's like a
combo piece somewhere. Not here, though.
Here it's just a Young Wolf. Dropping
this on turn one will surely keep your
opponents on the edge of their seats.
Next we have Arborio Grazer. This
doesn't even have power, so most of the
time this will be saddled and attacking
for two, but dropping a land from hand
is actually not bad cuz we will be
drawing a lot of cards if our plan
works. District Mascot, this is none of
the tribes highlighted here, but it's a
mount on its own, so yeah, saddle one is
nice and it pretty quickly becomes a
two-two, which is already above average
by our standards here. Swarm Shambler is
similar and pump itself as a mana sink.
The abilities are not relevant. Yeah,
we're kind of low on one drops here, so
I'm filling the gap with our trusty
elves. Yeah, I had to lie a little bit
on the job description. These are
probably the lowest quality creatures
they've ever ramped into in the history
of magic. But yeah, they are excellent.
Fast, efficient ramp also helps out with
saddling when the need arises. Okay,
back to the animals. With two drops, the
quality goes up, but not by much. We
have Bullwark Ox. Okay, this one is
actually excellent. Slowly pumping our
creatures and eventually becoming a
protection spell. And Felidar Cub to get
us out of the Decree of Silence lock.
Killed the Golda and the new wolf here
are excellent because early game we're
usually restrained by mana. Speaking of
that, we also have two low quality mana
dorks who should realistically be
unemployed, but this deck has heavy DEI
quotas to fill. Imagine you are a
Llanowar Elf looking at your colleague
with double pay. Anyways, just a few
more to round out the two drop slot. I'm
not going to bother to read them. But
actually the steed is pretty decent. Now
up to three drops. That's a pretty high
cost for what we're doing here, so we
expect quality. We start off pretty good
with two ramp spells. One is a wolf, the
other is everything. So is Arborio
Mauler. You know a tribal deck is
struggling when the changelings are some
of the best creatures. And there's also
P Metroid Blazer. It's a cool card, but
unfortunately it needs six energy, not
five, and our commander pumps by two,
not three. But we'll get there sometimes
and it is going to feel good. Krosan
Vorwsheep, a lot of our creatures are
beasts, so the abilities are pretty
relevant. Garruk's Harbinger and
Ferocious Pup is three mana for two
wolves. That's good, right? I mean, I
cut Elder Gargaroth for this, so it
better be good. And at four drop, we
have Ulvenwald Oddity. It's just a cool
card. Not sure how good it is, but it's
a cool card I've been wanting to play
and late game is kind of a finisher. And
finally, Blossoming Bogbeast.
And this card should be nuts, right? Cuz
it's a beast and it gives our team plus
two plus two, but then we have a bunch
of food tokens. So, every two mana we
spend will be another plus three to our
team. That's reasonable, right? Okay,
that's it for our creatures. But we do
have some non-creatures that create
creatures like the Ranger Class. Yeah, I
had to dig pretty deep, but it's
actually pretty good two mana two-two on
curve.
We probably won't have spare mana to
level up, but if we do, it's decent
value. It diversifies our board in case
of a board wipe. Also, for the late
game, we have a few enchantments like
Howling Moon. This will build us a board
state out of nowhere. And Trelasid's
Garden to make use of the food tokens.
Curious Herd can be hit or miss, but it
does have the potential to turn a empty
board into game-winning. And finally,
Fresh Meat as a part of our board wipe
prevention package, which also includes
Dawn's Truth, Heroic Intervention, and
Flawless Maneuver. Also, Akroma's Will,
but that needs no introduction. If you
know me, it goes into every creature
deck. Now, because we can establish a
board fairly quickly and and with that
board, we have card draw, we have
damage, we have life gain. So, we got to
keep them protected and a few specific
pieces just for our commander. And to
round things out, we have a few
miscellaneous pieces of utility. They're
pretty random cuz we have a lot of
things going on. We have food, we have
life gain, we have creatures. So, lots
of synergies we can look into and we
picked the best ones. To start off with
the boring stuff, The Great Henge seems
good here. And just a few backup pieces
of card draw like Return of the
Wildspeaker and Shamanic Revelation in
case people catch on and target Gendur a
lot. The next one, Aluren. I've been
wanting to play this card for a long
time. It seems to make sense here. We
have low drop creatures and we're
usually drawing more than we can play.
Now, is Is possible that our opponents
just straight up combos off with this?
Yes. But I've been holding this card for
10 years. I'm playing it. Also,
Collected Company, we're all about
diversity here. And Ninja Pizza to turn
our food tokens into treasures, which is
usually more useful. And Knight of the
Sweet's Revenge, which does it better
and is also a finisher. And a soaring,
and that rounds out our non-land cards.
For lands, it's nothing too special. You
can pretty much play whatever you want.
The two that are worth mentioning are
Contested Cliffs cuz it's a pretty sweet
payoff if you have enough beasts, which
I do. And Mutavault, it can saddle or be
saddled. That's pretty decent. A few
pieces to protect our commander and a
few MDFCs. Color facing is pretty
important here cuz we have a bit of an
aggressive mana curve, so I wouldn't go
too crazy with utility lands. We don't
need a lot of basics either cuz we're
not ramping too hard. So, yeah, just
make sure you play the ones without too
much drawback and you should be okay.
And that's it for our deck. It's not the
most explosive. It's a beatdown deck,
but it doesn't apply too much pressure
until a few turns into the game. It's
fairly consistent and resilient. I mean,
it's built around commander's ability to
draw cards, so you won't usually run out
of gas. Even if your board gets wiped,
you just replay the same cards again,
but with more potential for
explosiveness. The deck is very
straightforward. Just to figure out the
sequencing, like when to drop your
commander and when to fire off the big
on top turn, and you should do pretty
well. Now, the list included down below
is a full budget version, but this is
absolutely a great budget deck to build.
The core of the deck is about $50, and
every card above $5 is easily cuttable
except for maybe full throttle. And for
power, I think we sit at bracket two,
but we can challenge bracket three and
do reasonably well. And that's it for
today. Once again, I'm sponsored by
Kakapopo TCG, so if you like these sweet
designs, go to their site. You can use
my code levels, all caps, to get a
discount. This is Jen with Next Level
Commander. If you enjoy my content,
please like and subscribe. And we have
some sweet commanders coming out, and
yeah, I will be building a lot of them
here.
All right, see you.